guys come on
you're really gonna fight he's friggin
superheroes man they're so immature
Captain America Civil War is once again
directed by the Russo brothers as was
Winter Soldier and stars a ton of people
there's no point in naming them almost
all the Avengers are here present and
everyone seen this movie already hell my
grandpa saw this movie and he doesn't
even watch movies this movie is a story
of how our heroes turn on each other as
you probably know because of events in
the past despite their efforts to
evacuate citizens people died and people
are upset and it's time to put these
heroes in check and because of certain
laws that they're trying to pass this
turns our heroes against each other
sometimes when I see movies like this I
like to remind myself that when I grew
up in fact when I was a teenager for
goodness sakes I never imagined a movie
like this would ever exist and it's so
easy to forget in today's world where we
have so many different comic-book movies
that there was a time where a movie like
this was unheard of Winter Soldier took
the Captain America character in a far
more serious direction it was almost
like a 1970s spy film there was a lot of
grit to that movie there was a lot of
realism to it and a lot of people called
it the best Marvel movie to date civil
war does something very similar it takes
far more characters than Winter Soldier
did and it brings them down to earth yes
there's amazing choreography and fight
scenes and chase scenes and great stunt
work but at the core of this movie it's
a film about friendship and vengeance
and how when those two things come
together you can have a lot of problems
and it's a far more mature exploration
of that along with your typical Marvel
comedy and humor that you would come to
expect at this point but I was again
surprised by how serious this film
actually was it really took its time to
set up its conflicts it presents a real
grounded world where there are dire
consequences for mistakes and for these
larger-than-life superhero explosions
we're an island falls down and murders a
whole bunch of people there's gonna be
consequences angry people are gonna rise
out of that rubble and this movie
depicts that very well
it shows the political consequences of
such things as well as the very human
and intimate consequences of those
actions and that was very pleasing to
see along with this Mitch
exploration of some of these deeper
themes involving friendship and revenge
the movies also just a ton of fun the
action sequences in this movie not
there's things you can complain about in
this film there's things you can get
angry about there's one thing that no
one can say anything bad about and
that's the stunt team in this film they
did some of the best stunt work I've
seen in an action movie because a lot of
this is very noticeably in camera and
that's very impressive there's a lot of
incredible jaw-dropping stunts in this
film and the stunt team is to be praised
because everything looks very realistic
there's a lot of hand-to-hand combat a
lot of running chase scenes there is a
course CGI and big explosions and really
awesome moments like that but so much of
it felt in cameras similar to the way
Winter Soldier handled its action and
the Russo brothers being back to direct
set action is a great thing to see
because while I liked the action a lot
in Winter Soldier
I think they improved upon it here and
not just because there's more people
like black panther but because it's more
well handled let's talk about black
panther chadwick boseman man hole you're
a badass
I loved Black Panther in this film he
was extremely entertaining they take
what time they can to give you a reason
to get behind him and to understand him
because I didn't know much about Black
Panther at all going in but after having
seen this film I am totally behind this
guy and I can't wait for his solo film
chadwick boseman knocked it out of the
park spider-man this was the one that I
was really nervous about okay because
when I was a kid growing up Batman was
my favorite superhero then Superman then
spider-man spider-man was always my
favorite Marvel hero and I've been
waiting for him to be good in a Marvel
movie for quite some time in my humble
opinion this is the best incarnation of
the webhead since Sam Raimi spider-man 2
I adored him Tom Holland you are the
best good job the writing for him was so
on point he was a poor kid he could
barely afford anything he had a computer
from like 1989 or something and he was a
dumpster diver how great was that and
one Tony Stark finds him no spoilers of
course his suit it like it's
horrible he can't even afford to make a
good suit they understood the most
important aspects of what makes Peter
Parker entertaining
and lovable and they nailed it they
absolutely nailed it spider-man is
amazing in this film I can't wait to see
homecoming finally finally after 12
years now I've seen a good incarnation
of spider-man on the big screen thank
you thank you thank you and again with
no spoilers the central conflict that is
on display not just the physical
conflict between Iron Man and Captain
America the mental conflict you
understand where they're coming from
everyone in this movie including the
main villain you really understand why
they're doing what they're doing they're
not just like haha
I am a movie character and I'm in a
movie and you understand why they feel
the way they do some of these people
feel hurt some of them feel betrayed my
favorite comic book film of all time is
still The Dark Knight and one of the
reasons that film was so good is because
everyone's motivations very clear
including the Joker you understand where
he's coming from
he's not just a big movie character and
all the characters in this film no
matter what side they're on whether
they're a hero or a villain they all
have very clear reasons for being
present on screen and that is good
writing there isn't like a clear side
where you're like I side with you i side
with you I mean of course there's this
whole team cap and team Stark thing but
I honestly just think that's promotional
when you actually watch the movie it's
like you know I understand where
everyone's coming from here and it makes
it a very interesting moral dilemma
which is why when they start kicking ass
it rocks because you care about why
they're there and without spoiling
anything of course I'm just gonna say
ant-man
nailed it nailed it guys in the end cap
3 is everything I wanted it to be
Captain America is the only Marvel
series we've had so far that I feel each
installment has actually improved upon
the last one because Iron Man 2 sucked
Iron Man 3 was fine but it was too
strange to be better than one Avengers 2
wasn't as good as Avengers and Thor 2
and Thor are sort of interchangeable to
me this series the Captain America
series each one has built upon the last
gotten better and better and this film
is my favorite comic book movie I've
seen since the Dark Knight I'm gonna
give Captain America Civil War and a
plus I know this looks like considering
the last eight plus and so far the only
A+ I've given this year has been to
another comic book movie I look like the
biggest comic book fan of all time I'm
not
I just love good movies I can't really
say I've read too many comics in my life
this movie is well-made guys they put a
lot of money and a lot of effort behind
this and it paid off it was great
go see it have fun it's a great film
enjoy it so guys I have heard your
requests I understand you would like
more hilarious eighties and retro
rewinds I am finally starting to be able
to talk for longer periods of time
without my teeth hurting my new braces
so this weekend I'm going to do my best
to restart my hilarious AVI series I
can't say it's gonna be every week
because there's a lot of new releases
coming out soon but this weekend since
I've just praised Captain America a lot
I thought it'd be a lot of fun to
on his head because there's a 1990
adaptation of Captain America and man
it's a piece of we're gonna talk
about that this weekend and I'm looking
forward to that guys and I am still
gonna review the amazing spider-man 2
I've been doing one every month May is
gonna be the month in which I review the
amazing spider-man 2 there's just been
so many new releases there was like four
last weekend this month I'm definitely
reviewing amazing spider-man 2 to
complete that and give you my updated
thoughts on that film also a buddy mine
in Hollywood who is a masterful colorist
for film he knows so much about color
correction he's actually taught me quite
a bit and I'm still learning a lot he
wrote a very very very cool comic called
bizarre new world this is something he
was very passionate about it's a passion
project for him he took a lot of time to
write this during a writer strike and he
still was able to successfully pay
everyone involved who helped him and one
of the reasons I'm mentioning it is not
just because he's a friend of mine and I
feel that it's been overlooked I think
it's extremely well-written and the art
is amazing if you want to go to the link
in the description below to check out
his work I do think you'll like it
especially if your comic fans I think
it's very underrated very overlooked no
one ever talks about it and he put a lot
of effort and money into it and I do
think it's gone under a lot of people's
radars if you have some free time check
out his comic I do think it's worth your
time and skipper keep writing and keep
drawing because you are so amazing at it
and thank you if you're watching this
for all the help you've given me in
color
correction you're the best guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes